[Music]
there's just so many good things about
l.a yeah like like uh no rats yeah i
mean there are rats but it ain't like
new york like hollywood boulevard yeah
so i'm sorry stars in the ground yeah
pretty sick actually my [ __ ] on new york
either i do like new york what else the
405 the 405 about to say that
took the words out of my mouth 405.
sometimes like i just roll out at five
o'clock and just get on that [ __ ] just
to chill yeah i love doing that i love
how that's how chill la is at five
o'clock we all get on the freeway and we
kick back with each other because we
just wanna kind of vibe out we just
wanna vibe feel each other out a little
bit we're not trying to drive like fast
now i'm just trying to you know it's a
slow pace of life out here just chill
man it's more chill it's like we're all
we take our siestas in the morning yeah
and and our cars yeah gridlock traffic
it's a cultural thing about la where we
take two siestas a day yeah from seven
to nine exactly and five to seven no
it's because we all love podcasts so
much here yeah and audiobooks yeah you
know there's a big culture for that here
so we make sure we we make time for that
yeah
every morning i get up at five i get
ready i leave at six and i drive
somewhere two hours away
that's actually only like 20 minutes
away but i sit in traffic
um just to listen to an audio book
exactly and when i park i'm actually
parking at um
a mountain to take a hike yes i take a
two-hour hike to listen to another
audiobook yeah yeah and then by the time
there i'll try to find like a bird
scooter at the base of the mountain get
a quick podcast in on my way to a
restaurant where i'll listen to another
audiobook doesn't sound like a vlog
sounds like a good vlog right yeah get
back on my bird scooter go back to my
car get back in traffic to drive home
yeah listen to my final audio book of
the day yep and then i'm ready to start
my day yeah
so
yep i see new york is so fast-paced yeah
how do we make money how do we make
money here how do we get here a
restaurant gotta go meet this product
for drinks
networking and everything
listen to an audiobook yeah
when are you learning let me ask you
that question yeah what are you learning
you can't learn in new york because it's
like i'm learning 60 of my day i'm
learning
because i spend 60 of my day in my car
yeah and i listen to podcasts and 30 of
my day is sleeping and 10 is eating and
you can't learn in new york because like
you're going to wake up and then you got
to run to the train that's only 10
minutes exactly and the train ride it's
too noisy 20 people dancing on the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
reciting this mantra
to
here's another good thing about l.a in
and out yeah because i like to learn
when i'm waiting for my food yep and
those drive-through lines are at least
an hour every time which is good which
is there i mean i wouldn't have it any
other way yeah that's how you know the
food's fresh yeah takes way too [ __ ]
long to get exactly i'm listening to
dune right now yeah not the audiobook
the movie nice
it's good
i put it on just kind of imagining what
the characters are doing yep what space
they're in let me tell you it's not that
beautiful of a movie
yeah dude
yeah la's just a [ __ ] whole third world
country
[Laughter]
yeah that's why the 405 is a dirt road
yeah that's why you can always pull off
on the 405 to a random farm and
shoot a cow with a rock with a rocket
launcher for 20 u.s exactly yeah
exactly it's such a third world [ __ ]
city yeah i like l.a too because every
time i get pulled over by the cops i can
just bribe them if you speak the
language yeah otherwise you're paying a
lot [ __ ] more yeah the other part
that i love about uh living in our third
world [ __ ] city is you can bargain
for everything exactly yeah you go get
gas and they're like it's six dollars a
gallon now because if you know what the
guy said on cnn you're like i don't feel
like it yeah i'll give you two dollars
yeah yeah when you go to like pay rent
on a home you can bargain that too yeah
definitely yeah well they're like this
house is two million dollars you're like
that's four
dollars yeah how about 10 yeah and you
get it yeah
sick yeah yep yeah
la
at least sick
i know casey maybe should um
i don't know he's moving back to new
york yeah
i mean yeah
yeah he's good why does it matter where
he lives to everyone i don't know that's
the [ __ ] i don't like that is so
mind-blowing to me is like all these
nerds on twitter they're like dude you
gotta come back to new york dude i miss
seeing you yeah get some real [ __ ]
friends
you wake up every day hoping a youtuber
is on a boosted board just like cruising
past the coffee shop what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you trying to create some
weird like where's waldo life that you
live no i miss seeing casey on 42nd
street
shut the [ __ ] up
i'll move to new york and dress like
casey and replace him i'm casey nicer
stats
nicer stats
okay yeah look at my social blade [ __ ]
yeah
i'm going up i'm gonna buy a bunch of
subscribers so i have more than him on
everything more followers more
everything i'ma [ __ ] buy fake views
inflate my [ __ ] to the fullest what i'm
casey neiser stats
i'm gonna have and i love l.a yeah i'm
gonna have his hair yeah i'm gonna make
elena dye her hair
what's this girl's name candace candace
we're going to adopt two randoms
we're gonna adopt two random babies i'm
gonna live exactly his life yeah i'm
gonna freak him the [ __ ] out he's gonna
move back to town and then i'm gonna hop
off my boosted board and be like what
are you doing here and then as soon as
he starts talking i would like try to
mirror him uvkc
uh uh
[Laughter]
what's up guys i'm back in new york
what are you doing what are you doing
stop
are those
you won't win casey this is my town now
it would be kind of funny if he got to
new york got on a boosted board got his
camera out and he's like i'm back in new
york guys it feels so good hold on hold
on stops and you stop what are you doing
on my morning routine bro
what do you mean wait
who are you
who are you
casey nicer
why does it say that on your shirt
i'm the better you
i'm like you but nicer i'm like you but
nicer more rich more views
and i don't think anywhere's a third
world [ __ ] city
because i have a more expanded world
view than you because i've done more
traveling than you
i'm nicer stats look at my passport
page after page of stamps 150 countries
visited where the [ __ ] have you been
they've been to rural parts of morocco
didn't think so loser because you surf
all right hey
all right relax with that [ __ ] we got
chav mr beast yeah casey nicer stats and
the evil mark robert and evil marc
rubber [ __ ] those and and always in
pain
josh richards yeah we're gonna have like
a whole roster of like
just like [ __ ] up mutated influencers
yeah
yeah or parodies or and and
uh demented gary vee yeah
we need to create we have jim like make
this like they're all standing there
like the cast of marvel you know that's
what i'm saying we have to make our own
like avengers film yeah we're
interesting
it's the other side of the coin there's
like some portal to like another
dimension yeah and it's like string
theory becomes reality yeah and then it
demented garyvee's in the front what's
up [ __ ] faces gonna kill your whole
[ __ ] family yeah and mark robert's
like uh you ever seen meth go in your
mom's [ __ ] in casey neiser stats like
i just left 67 dslrs in my car overnight
and i don't give a [ __ ] if it gets
broken into it's a giveaway because
unlike you i don't care about money
casey yeah who are these guys
[Laughter]
it's me beast
and i'm here to give these hoes birkins
i'm about to break into casey's car and
give every single one of these cameras
to these hoes at 11.
the five of them are secretly trying to
take over the whole world
all under
under demented garyvee's [ __ ]
guidance dude that's cool but imagine
your mom getting strangled
imagine this whole city imprisoned
what if we put everyone in here into
labor
make them build a whole city for us
sounds sick is that mark grover yeah
mark grover's like i'm gonna build
infinity handcuffs that are literally
unbreakable by any human
the start of it would be evil mr beast
getting a time machine and rolling time
back to the start of his squid games
adventure then on the final day where
they go to shoot evil mr beast
captures regular mr beast and he puts
makeup on so he hides all his tattoos
then he's like hey everyone guess what i
have a special guest it's my good friend
mark rober we're gonna make the game a
little more fun and then evil mark rover
walks out in regular clothes but because
he does so many hard-ass drugs he's way
too thin yeah to be regular mark robin
okay so he pulls his hat off and they're
like that's not mark then he throws the
infinity handcuffs in the air they're
all drones by the way so they just fly
and attach to all the contestants okay
and then evil mr beast reveals himself
oh i see and then demented gary vee
walks out of one of the little huts on
red light green light he just shoots one
of the contestants just cuz okay yeah
yeah hello
imagine this
oh my god and then you ever see mark
roberts like squirrel obstacle course
yeah that's the last stage of the squid
games for humans it's that but 400 feet
in the air for humans yeah
demented garyvee walks into the red
light green light and he's like
where's number 67 the girl in the show
walks right out to her
this will be nothing like the show
[Laughter]
where's 67
cool
oh [ __ ]
why gary
[Laughter]
because life's not fair then casey nicer
stats pulls up on a boosted board and
he's like mushrooms are a natural way to
decompose a body he just throws mushroom
dust
onto the body
and then they all compete and they do
the mark rover human squirrel challenge
all those who win get to do labor for
the rest of their lives for demented
garyvee okay yeah yeah nice no they're
forced to be mr beast's friends oh okay
for like 20 more years yeah yeah yeah
and every time the camera's on them they
have to like laugh and make some stupid
as evil mr beast's videos get crazier
and wilder and
more [ __ ] up yeah today we're gonna
kill a thousand crustaceans by hand yeah
and my friends are gonna do it
oh jimmy jimmy
oh and you know who would be like a
weird like b villain who would [ __ ] up
their like everyone's plans he's like a
rogue villain mr based no no i was gonna
be the guy who wanted to work for logan
paul
[Laughter]
he'll be the psycho in the whole thing
oh [ __ ] it's logan paul's assistant no
i'm here to blow up the whole thing man
logan give me a job mr beast
i want to be your friend
come on i want to be one of the friends
i can do whatever and he killed all of
his 200 come on fake imprisoned
well you don't really have an option
lord knows you need friends right now
and i'm the one and i'm the one dragging
a giant stick of dynamite yeah he's like
wait
where's my hog
where's my pet hog
do you like bacon mr beast don't you
dare
leave my hog alone
oh no guys he's gonna kill my hog
jim animate all that
you have 24 hours
you